christmas is coming early for
PlayStation 4 owners sony has sent out a
survey hinting at future features for
firmware updates including being able to
change your PSN ID and having custom
backgrounds and new face plates are set
to be released in November so maybe not
the most exciting Christmas but still
sony has sent out survey asking
PlayStation 4 users what they think are
the most important features that should
be added to the console among the
choices are much requested features such
as the ability to change a playstation
network ID custom backgrounds and the
option to hide or completely remove
items from the library function also
found on the list of options are psone
classics and ps2 classics indicating the
platform holder may be gauging the
demand for more releases the survey also
asks when respondents expect PlayStation
to release the next big system software
update with a range of timeframe
starting from before the end of 2015 and
going up to 2017 or later available to
pick the last update 3.0 was released on
sep tember 30th it added a number of
features including Twitter sharing for
videos tweaks to the interface for
streaming on YouTube and an increase in
online storage capacity from one
gigabyte to 10 gigabyte for PS plus
members the PlayStation 4 will also be
getting custom face plates in the UK and
Australia allowing players to change the
color of the top of the console the
faceplates come in six colors neon
orange aqua blue glacier white gold
silver and red the gold and silver
colors will not be available in the UK
or Ireland with the rest will launch on
November eighteenth are you planning to
buy one of the faceplates what features
would you like to see added to the
PlayStation 4 an update for point now
let us know in the comments or you can
find me on Twitter at how not to draw
i'm kate and thanks for watching